there is one style of breathing that is
more effective than other styles for
reducing your stress and improving your
mood and is called cyclic sighing this
is new research that came out of
Stanford University and here's how
cyclic sign works you inhale through
your nose and you fill up your lungs and
then you inhale again to maximally fill
out your lungs so you breathe in and
it's a full breath through your nose but
then you can hit it again a little bit
just to maximally expand your lungs and
then you slowly exhale all the way out
through your mouth both inhales are
through the nose and the slow exhale is
through the mouth do that for five
minutes and it should improve your
stress and your mood let me know in the
comments if it worked for you